SPEAKER: In this
Cloud Minute, you'll
learn how to quickly
deploy a Spring Boot
application to Google App
Engine standard for Java 11
using a JAR file.
First, create a Spring
Boot application
from Spring Initializer.
Add the Web Starter so you
can respond to web requests.
In the Generate the Application,
create a controller that simply
returns hello from App Engine.
Boot the application and
the package the JAR file.
Use gcloud command
to deploy the JAR.
Once deployed, you can
access the application
with the projects
URL on appspot.com.
Alternatively, you can also
create an app.yaml file
to configure instance class,
environmental variable,
and deploy this
application directly
with Maven or Gradle
using App Engine plugins.
Learn more about App
Engine standard Java 11
runtime on the
documentation website.